nochmal alles lüge herzlich willkommen
meine lieben freunde am montag natürlich
wieder zu einer neuen episode von hier
selbstverständlich bei den bisherigen
folgen wobei man das mit luca ebenfalls
der fall war es auch das heutige video
wieder freundlich unterstützt wurden von
google play im rahmen der playon
kampagne und heute spielen wir den bus
simulator
ich war 1948 war das jetzt auf jeden
fall unser extrem geil das gerät mit dem
wiederum fahren werden von dem
unternehmen lukas laden ja das ist mein
busunternehmen ich würde sagen wir
fahren heute einfach mal von hamburg
nach stuttgart und zwar starten wir ganz
entspannt um 10 30 morgens akzeptieren
ticketpreis 24 euro nach ein bisschen
günstiger oder ja dann lassen wir es
einfach beiden szenen hin wichtig
gastronomie würde ich sagen die wir noch
ein bisschen mit wir nehmen themen wie
dem café mit hotdogs koffer packen alles
ein können sich alles auch ich kann nur
bis zum 4
naja egal staaten einfach mal das hier
bin ich der firma arbeitet exakt so aus
wie ich so freunde der ganze apparat
gestartet jetzt mal ich würde sagen ich
wieso kann ich nicht geben
gauleiter und jetzt geben wir einfach
mal gas und statten wir unseren bus wir
fahren wo fahren wir dann wo a o mein
gott das ist gar nicht mit ach das ist
mein gott lenkt so sein
tschuldigung liebe fahrgäste allerdings
können wir jetzt einfach auf reverse
gehen und fahren wir mal ein bisschen
nach hinten genau schön das wird schon
mal direkt die kamera jetzt gehen wir
allerdings wieder in den drive mord und
fahren nach vorne kommen oder rechts ist
supermarkt wollen auch was zu essen so
wie kann ich da jetzt mal aussteigen
das bin ich
ich habe eine beifahrerin das sieht auch
nicht so gesund aus gerade mit meinen
händen sowie unser bus auf jeden fall
von vorne aus von oben aus so ein
bisschen gta perspektive allerdings
schauen wir uns das ganze mal so an und
fahren jetzt wir müssen nämlich leute
einsammeln auch gott
es steht also eine karte im weg ich bin
der beschissene busfahrer der welt jetzt
geht s los meine lieben freunde so
müssen wir da hinfahren
da vorne steht irgendwie so ein pfeil
ich weiß allerdings nicht soll ich
erstmal halten oder wie ada ach so ok
fahren wir hin
hallo ich stehe doch hier perfekt aber
gut fahren wir vorne immer perfekt rein
so sagt bleiben stehen und jetzt sehen
wir schon sie müssen den kofferraum für
koffer finden
ok
sie müssen die türe öffnen sagen die
passagiere ja könnt ihr nicht aus dem
fenster springen
aha na gut dann kommt man raus freunde
ok cool das ist der fritz dieter der
stellt sich vor die koffer damit ja
keiner ran kommt die ladys sind drin was
du zu dir nach dk so leute die gäste
sind drin von einem manchmal die tür zu
und auch das gepäck dingen zu wir sind
im reverse gang das heißt wir fahren
jetzt mal nach hinten und fahren nach
hinten
wir fahren wir müssen unser name mal
machen den laden
nach einem kleinen zwischenfall hier
gerade beim ausparken würde ich sagen
bewegen wir uns jetzt allerdings auf
nach berlin
nach stuttgart nach münchen von wo
verborgen
es ist nicht verwunderlich alles an ist
es ist sprachen lernen ihr busfahrer hat
mich mal deutscher war ja kein auto
fahren
was ist das hier denn ich spiele den bus
simulator und kommen nicht mal
vernünftig vor dem parkplatz weg was ist
mit ihr denn hier
hallo ticker zu einsteigen bei mir in
den laden
ich sehe sich durch den putz
durchgelaufen
ja gut wenn du nicht mit nach hamburg
stuttgart münchen in berlin mit diesem
modell wuppertal west keine ahnung wo
ich jetzt gerade hin verwendet die mit
wild dann kommt sein die mit so wir
fahren jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal raus
sind vom platz und fahren jetzt auf die
autobahn
darauf muss du jeden bus musst du jeden
port an fahren lernen erst einmal
deutsch bruder wir fordern ist weit
rechts abbiegen die kurve ist allerdings
perfekt geeignet für unseren racing bus
da müssen wir gar nicht abbremsen wir
brettern mit 66 km/h darüber kurzer als
kurz ins löwenzahn aber gut okay wir
haben hier ein paar ahlmann standort die
wollen unbedingt in den anderen firmen
wurden sandwich verteilen denn erstmals
schritt schreiben bei mir gibt's nur
pizza im fonds entweder du frist das
oder steigs halt aus ihr freundlicher
und kompetenter busfahrer eine tanke ich
brauche ihnen auch ein bisschen tank
ging's auch musst du jeden bord anfahren
was ist denn ein board ich glaube ihm
einen bordstein aber so weit kann ich
nicht schalten schalten das witzig weil
ich hab eigentlich ein automatikgetriebe
und egal
mach doch mal platz vier was ist hätte
gedacht das ist ein wlan-zugang gibt da
das mit doppel s du blödmann aber gut
wir haben jetzt auf jeden fall die
tankstelle gefunden und ich parke jetzt
einfach mal die gebühr wird von ihrem
firmenkonto abgezogen ja aber lukas
laden hat 70 milliarden euro hoffen
konnte von der ist es gar kein problem
mit ein bisschen schneller tanken wir
haben es eilig aber gut weiter geht's
die fahrgäste wir bewegen uns weiter die
s 600
wir sollten ihnen die 600 kilometer von
hamburg nach stuttgart fahren keine
ahnung wie ich das hier in dem video
hinkriegen soll arbeitet euro das ist
abkürzung hier können wir das ist auch
ich kann ich kann nicht ich kann nicht
was ich bin zu jung um zu sterben kommt
leute das war ein tannenbaum mein gott
ich dachte halt bisschen
weihnachtsstimmung hier im februar
wieder so eine komische kurve an die
muss ich aber gar nicht fahren
ich war hier gut da muss ich halt
autobahn fahren vor allem autobahnen
luca wieder gar keinen sinn ist einfach
so eine stinknormale bundesstraße
allerdings müssen wir hier jetzt rechts
abbiegen und jetzt fahren wir auf die
autobahn drauf meine lieben freunde also
jetzt wird spaßig so erstmal
schulterblick ok alles fragen musst du
jeden port anfahren das ist kein
bordstein das ist eine leitplanke mein
lieber herr fritz dieter gesangsverein
dahin aber gut freunde weiter geht's
hier auf jeden fall nach rom mit unserem
kegelverein hinten drin
wir fahren mit 87 km/h aber jegliche
spuren darüber dass uns kann gar nichts
aufhalten kubala rechts der grüne
schlumpf mir sind schlümpfe grünen die
haben ja unten auch ein mikrofon von
daher sei jetzt einfach mal wir sind für
sie da wo
angenehme fahrt haben steht ihnen
jederzeit zur verfügung
ja das können ja sonst auch so sagen
ihre anfahrt zeit ist gekommen
schließlich wünscht ihnen einen
angenehmen tag
wir sind schon längst abgefahren aber
gut wir konzentrieren uns hier weiter
auf unsere frage nach frankreich wir
haben nur noch 420 kilometer um geld
ja liebe fahrgäste
ich hoffe ist es nicht verwunderlich
kommen halt doch dein maul ein ich muss
die leute hier auch irgendwie wir holen
und man kennt sie in deutschland
überholt man ja selbstverständlich von
rechts machen standstreifen also wie
auch sonst davon ist im stau
das aber nicht schlimm weil unser brust
in lukas laden der panzer hat von daher
können wir hier ein bisschen einfach
zwischendurch studium achtung heiß und
fettig wir müssen nach belgien meine
lieben freunde sorgt sagt hier drumrum
bahn muss du jeden bord anfahren das war
ein auto mein lieber freund sein nein
nein bleibt auf der fahrbahn bleibt auf
der fahrbahn mein gott oft gerade noch
so gerettet freunde hat keiner was zu
beanstanden meine passagiere denn ich
habe alles im griff das ist das für
komische umweg um eine optimale
runterbrettern hallo wo der
doppeldeckerbus der kommt bestimmt hat
aus london
wir sind allerdings immer noch auf dem
weg in die niederlande meiner lieben
freunde haben nur noch 319 kilometer vor
uns ja wollen ein paar lieder singen
sonst zur abwechslung mal eine busfahrt
die ist kacke jahr mit luca sind wir tot
wenn der vorne sitzt am steuer ja dann
ist es an nichts
nicht geheuer der ist auch ungeheuer und
dem verbrennen wir nachher im feuer
also sorry klar man kann mir vorwerfen
was man will von wegen hey ich habe hier
ein bisschen vielleicht den einen oder
anderen baum mitgenommen das eine oder
andere auto und leicht beschädigt aber
wir sind schnell
wir sind wirklich schnell da kann man
nicht sagen dank mal kurzen eintrag man
nicht wir haben ein ziel und das ist
russland muss eine pause einlegen
wir brauchten pausen 2000 jahre später
ok meine damen und herren wir haben noch
150 kilometer vor uns allerdings müssen
wir nun hier rechts abfahren
von daher würde ich sagen wir reduzieren
die geschwindigkeit definitiv euro das
meer sogar schon okay
hat er
gerade als unfall gewertet hat er ist
wirklich ein unfall
ja sapperlot normale euch bringe ich nie
wieder nach spanien an der stelle durch
das häufig wie die jetzt allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde an der
stelle geht noch mal ein dickes dickes
dankeschön raus an google play die im
rahmen der player und kampagnen das
heutige video wieder freundlicher weise
unterstützt haben wenn ihr auch block
auf bus simulator habt und euch denkt
hey ich kann das definitiv besser als
luca dann findet ihr einen link
selbstverständlich und in der video
beschreibung und jetzt befinden wir uns
auch schon hier im auto meiner lieben
freunde hier findet ihr einerseits
nochmal bus simulator das spiel
eingewendet da könnte darauf schicken
gelangt direkt in dem place de könnt
euch das ganze herunter laden und ihr
findet ja auch das letzte video von
mobile man es mit luca eingeblendet da
habe ich nämlich die elder scrolls
blades gespielt in dem spiel war ich
auch nicht viel besser als wir